we have a voicemail number today from
someone who is absolutely completely
utterly unhinged that's all I'll say
let's listen to it together you got one
hell of a nerve may confront a
Republicans man don't you look you
freakin Democrat to the one the cause of
the sea legal aliens but yeah your
program stinks right what I don't know
that I even have a comment she's fired
up and ready to go she fired up and
ready to go no doubt about it on the
bonus show today an update on the David
Pakman show on amazon prime an exciting
update and an opportunity for the
audience to participate in that exciting
expansion I will talk about more
protests over the weekend at airports
here in Boston at Copley Square how long
will it go on etc etc i also want to
talk about very strange set of
circumstances where as a result of the
New York City yellow cab drivers that
they drive yellow cabs they're not
yellow drivers I just want to be super
clear there I can see how that could be
taken out of context the drivers of
yellow cabs in New York City were
refusing to take passengers to JFK
Airport in support of the protests
against the immigration been uber made a
move that was sort of like a
strikebreaking move and then lift came
back in and is donating a million bucks
to the ACLU and is supportive of those
protesting the immigration band so I
want to talk about all of that on the
bonus show today I will remind you that
david pakman show coffee is almost ready
to go on sale I'm finalizing the final
last details in the next day or two and
I really look forward to telling you
about that you can also get instant
access to the bonus show by signing up
at david pakman.com slash membership the
normal rates are really low we're
talking about pennies a day but if that
is too high for some of our viewers I
don't want the price to be a barrier to
growing our subscriber base so use the
coupon code I voted 17 you can use the
coupon code I voted 17 on the membership
of your choice it'll give you a huge
discount that's what people are telling
me anyway
and then you will get instant access to
the bonus show which starts in mere
seconds